[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar introduction to antibodies
i am kayleigh bach of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by leica biosystems
to learn more visit leica-biosystems.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
denise wooley laboratory workflow
implementation consultant emea at leica
biosystems
denise you may now begin your
presentation
but now
my name is denise wooley and before i
took on this role as
implementation consultant i used to be a
senior scientist in antibody research
and development at the leica biosystems
site in newcastle at the united kingdom
today i'm going to talk to you about
introduction to antibodies
so viruses bacteria toxins
anything that doesn't belong in the body
is generally considered foreign matter
therefore it's potentially pathogenic
which means it has the potential to
cause disease in the body that it's
infected
antibodies are specialized proteins
called immunoglobulins
and these are generated by the body's b
cells in response to this foreign matter
to the viruses the bacteria the toxins
now our cells have protein structures
attached to them which identify our
cells as belonging to us
and these are recognized by our immune
cells
sometimes this recognition system can
malfunction which causes autoimmune
diseases
but generally
anything unlabeled in our bodies is
targeted for destruction by our immune
cells
but our cells are not
so antibodies immunoglobulins are
roughly y-shaped and are formed by four
polypeptide chains
two of the four chains are heavy chains
and two of the four chains are light
chains
the difference between the heavy and the
light chain is the amino acid sequence
and as the name suggests
heavy chains were more than the light
chains
an average heavy chain is about 50
kilodollars which is double the weight
of an average light chain at 25
kilodaltons
a single heavy chain will combine with a
single light chain to form a heterodimer
structure
two heterodimers join to form a complete
immunoglobulin
the join between the heterodimers is a
disulfide bridge and this acts as a sort
of hinge which gives flexibility to the
y-shaped structure that you can see on
the screen
there are four sorry there are two types
of light chain not four
you've got kappa and you've got lambda
and generally there's no functional
difference between the two
now antibodies will only ever have
cappuccins or light chain or lambda
chains they'll not have one of each
and in humans capper chains are usually
more abundant than the lambda chains
with a ratio of two to one
structurally antibodies have two
significantly different areas
the first can be called the constant
domain so this forms the lower part of
the y shape and it only includes the
heavy chains
the variable domain is the second area
and this includes the heavy and light
chains at the top of the y shape the
arms of the y
the variable domain is so called due to
the variations or differences in the
sequence of the first 110 amino acids in
the heavy and light chains
this is the area of the antibody that
can detect and bind to its specific
antigen
the variability of the amino acids allow
the antibody to be generated against the
specific protein
the heavy chain sequences
these form the constant domain
so this gives rise to the antibody
isotype which we'll discuss in a couple
of slides
the constant domain is the same for
every antibody within that specific
isotype so it's easily recognized by the
host immune cells
the variable domain also contains the
fab region
fab stands for
fragment antigen binding
and as it sounds it's the area of
antigen binding
the constant domain contains the fc
region or fragment crystallizable
now there's no antigen binding
capabilities in this region
this fragment is responsible for
interacting with the host immune cells
so it's easily identified by the immune
cells
the flexibility from the disulfide
bridge allows the two fab fragments so
the two arms of the y
to move independently of each other
which allows them to interact with more
antigens
the y-shaped structure allows for
variability in the fab regions whilst
maintaining the similarity in the fc
region
so
it allows the antibody to detect a range
of antigens
but it still allows the host immune
cells to be able to recognize itself
recognize the fc region the constant
domain and generate an immune response
as mentioned earlier the isotypes are
determined by the constant domain the fc
regions of the heavy chains
there's five different isotypes of
mammalian antibodies and they're
categorized by the sequence and number
of amino acids in the heavy chains
the five sequences are labeled with
lowercase letters from the greek
alphabet
so you've got igg which is gamma igm mu
iga alpha
igd delta and ige epsilon
we're going to go through one at a time
igg containing the gamma chain
so this is the most abundant
immunoglobulin in the human body
it's very small
it exists as a single y-shaped structure
with a molecular weight of about 150
kilodolls
now most pathogenic infections are
confronted by igg antibodies and this is
part of the
humoral or cell-mediated immune response
which basically means it's an immune
response driven by antibodies
the fab fragment it binds to a specific
piece of the pathogen which then
triggers the immune response
the fc region recognized by the specific
immune cells now these cells are
phagocytes
the phagocytes such as macrophages
engulf and digest the pathogen or an
infected human cell
destroying the potential pathogen and
saving the host from from infections
multiple igg antibodies tend to bind to
a single pathogen or an infected cell
and it produces a courting of igg
antibodies all around it and this is
called opsinization
igg is further subdivided into four more
classes
and they're numbered one to four
with igg one is the most abundant
nigg for is the least abundant
the subclasses generally are very
similar but some differences are seen in
the disulfide bridge of the hinge area
igg3
has around four times as many amino
acids in the gamma chain
in the heavy gamma chain as the other
subtypes do
and it's this subtype that's involved
with the immune complement cascade
so this is the the cascade which
triggers the phagocytic response to
opsinization
another interesting fact about igg is it
can cross the placenta
and it can confer degree of immunity to
a developing fetus
igm has the mu heavy chain
so this is the first antibody generated
in response to the body detecting a
pathogen
the pentameric structure makes it the
largest antibody found in mammals and
that's five individual igm units that
have joined together
sometimes it can exist as a hexamer
which is six units
but it's most commonly found as a
pentamer
so these individual
units are formed into the pentameter and
held in place by the disulfide bonds and
adjoining chain
which is also called a j chain
it's the presence of the j chain that's
thought to trigger the formation of more
pentimers when there's loads of single
igm antibodies
in the area in the vicinity
the pentamer structure has ten separate
fab fragments so technically it combined
up to 10 individual antigens which makes
it extremely effective
and just like igg3
igm also triggers the complement cascade
and phagocytosis
due to its larger size it's generally
found in lymphatic and larger blood
vessels around the body
iga
so this is formed with the alpha heavy
chain
it's found in monomeric in dimeric
formats so one or two units
with the dimeric structure connected by
another j chain and a secretory
component so we have
iga1
and iga2
iga1 is the monomeric version the single
unit usually found in blood zero
iga 2 is called secretory iga or s iga
and is most commonly present in the
dimeric form with the secretory
component
so siga or iga2 is found in abundance of
mucosal surfaces
such as those that are in prostatic
ducts endometrium and especially the
respiratory and the gi tract
anything with mucus basically
the scorchery component protects the
antibody from undergoing digestion
digestion by gastric pepsin
which is what makes it capable of
survival in the harsh acidic stomach
environment
the secretary component also allows the
diamond format to be secreted in mucus
and body
body fluids and it's found in high
concentrations
in human colostrum and breast milk
which goes towards conferring some
degree of immunity to a breastfed
newborn baby
the primary rule of iga is to protect
the host from ingested or inhaled
pathogens
so unlike igm and igg
it doesn't trigger the complement
cascade in the blood
iga works by forming a physical barrier
between the pathogen and the epithelial
cells
it stops the pathogen from getting into
the horse
it creates a barrier and it protects the
mucosal linings
once it stopped
the invasion the infection of the
pathogen
in the gi tract you've got the
peristaltic motion
of the bowel of the
the muscle around the the bowel organs
which push the pathogen out of the body
now as of this recording immunoglobulin
d is the least understood antibody
it's formed by the delta heavy chain and
exists in a monomeric form which is
located primarily on b cell membranes
and it's usually in conjunction with an
igm
it's not present in very high levels and
it has a very short half-life
of two to three days it's thought to
make up about one percent of all
immunoglobulins in the body
and currently it's thought that it's
involved with tamping down autoimmune
reactions
but so much more work is is needed
before we consider for definite
ige uses the epsilon heavy chain
and usually it's produced in response to
parasitic infections
however we tend to associate it more
with allergic reactions
so it's present in small levels in a
monomeric form
estimated at about 0.0002
of total immunoglobulin in the body
it's usually found in mucosal surfaces
such as those in the respiratory in the
gi tract
now allergic reactions are
basically an overreaction of the immune
system in response to something that it
shouldn't really be allergic to
it's term this
item is
it's not a pathogen we'll call it the
allergen
the first time an allergen enters the
body and this could be something like
pollen
entering the respiratory system
it's presented to the b cells
who differentiate into a specialized
type of b cell called plasma cells
now these cells are short-lived and all
they do is exist to produce multiple
copies of ige
which will detect the specific antigen
that triggered its formation so it'll
detect the specific allergen
the constant fc region of the ige has a
very high affinity
for certain white blood cells and these
are
basophils and mast cells
and this allows the antibody to bind to
these cells
so the next time the allergen enters the
host body
they're ready waiting and we'll detect
it so there's no delay in an immune
response
so on re-exposure to the allergen
the b cells don't need to have the
allergen presented to it to form plasma
cells and to produce ige
the antibodies are already there
and they're attached to the mast cells
in the basophils
so every time the allergen is present in
the host body
the ige antibodies bind to it and
trigger the adjoined mast cell to
release histamine from the grant from
its granules
and its histamine that causes the
allergic symptoms
it initiates the inflammatory response
and that can manifest as a runny nose
watery eyes
coughing itching throat problems
breathing
and in extreme cases it can result in
anaphylactic shock
so we've covered the structure of the
five different isotypes and now we're
going to discuss specificity and in
vitro manufacture of antibodies over the
next few slides
for some reason i struggle to see a
specificity so i have to say it very
slowly
antibody specificity is the ability of
the fab regions to bind to one or more
antigens
so the difference in the amino acid
residues of the antigen binding site is
what's responsible for the specificity
antibodies detect unique areas on
antigens called epitopes
and every antigen has multiple epitopes
monoclonal antibodies will only detect a
single epitope on the antigen
and that's the one that triggered their
formation
polyclonal antibodies are more
generalized and they can recognize more
than one epitope on an antigen
so therefore
monoclonal antibodies are more specific
than mono than polyclonal antibodies
which makes them usually more expensive
they're more expensive to develop and
they take longer to manufacture
polyclonal antibodies are generally
cheaper and quicker to manufacture as
they produce from several different
b-cell clones
but they don't have the same degree of
specificity as a monoclonal antibody
now both types of antibody have their
benefits and also have the disadvantages
it really depends on what you want to
use them for
so why are we talking about antibodies
why are they so important
antibodies are a crucial part of cancer
research around the globe
normal mammalian cells express a large
range of different proteins that can be
on the cell membrane in the cell
cytoplasm and on the cell nucleus
these proteins are altered when a cell
undergoes malignant changes
the normally expressed proteins they can
change in structure
they can stop it the cells can stop
expressing the usual proteins
they can
the changes can cause the cells to start
expressing different proteins they can
start over expressing the usual proteins
they can express different
proteins they can stop expression
altogether
so it's these changes in the express
proteins that are detected using a
technique called immunohistochemistry
which is abbreviated to ihc
or immunocytochemistry
which is abbreviated to icc
ihc
is when the techniques performed on
tissue on pieces of tissue
nicc is when it's performed on
individual cells groups of individual
cells but generally people say one or
the other to cover both
so generating high quality specific
robust antibodies for research is quite
a rigorous process
against human cancers what we need to do
is
isolate
the tumor cells and purify them you pick
the tumor that you want to raise
antibodies against
the tumor that's growing in the human
you take it out you harvest the tumor
cells you purify it you make sure you've
just got tumor cells
the relevant proteins
that are the the cells that are
expressing the proteins these proteins
are harvested
and the tiny protein fragments
are used to inoculate specialized lab
animals
and this triggers their immune reaction
within the lab animals
the
the animal's immune response recognizes
it as not being labeled as self it's
foreign
so it has an immune reaction
the antibodies it produces are designed
to attack the proteins that have been
inoculated into it
once there's a sufficient degree of
these antibodies
the animal splenic cells are isolated
these splenic cells
are introduced to a specialized
malignant hg prt negative cell line
so
i'm going to say this it's quite hard
biology can be compared to learning a
new language so please bear with me
but h g p
r t stands for
hypoxanthine guanine phosphorus ribosyl
transferes
which is basically an enzyme that's
found in the human body
and the cell line that we use is
negative for it so all of that just to
be negative
the myeloma cell line is immortal
and once it's fused with the splenic b
cells
it generates immortalized b cells which
produce the specific antibody against
the inoculated human proteins
this fusion is called a hybridoma
now any infused cells are removed using
hyperxanthine amino peterine thymodine
or hat medium
which is easier to say than the other
one
it prevents the unfused cells from
undergoing cell division so they'll die
off and not form part of the hybridoma
initially
within the hybridoma there will be
multiple b-cell clones and they will
produce a range of antibodies against
various epitopes on the protein antigens
to produce a monoclonal antibody
you need to isolate a single
immortalized b-cell clone to do this you
have several different dilutions of hat
medium over multi-well plates you keep
diluting out and out until eventually
you end up with a single cell
and a single well in the plate
and it's this single cell
that will be cultured
that will grow
and will eventually produce a supply of
monoclonal antibodies
it will be replicated it will produce
the specific monoclonal antibody that it
was first raised against
it's a very complicated process and i've
shortened it down to like
six very very simplified steps
but you can appreciate it's not simple
but it is a very important process
so now we've made the antibodies
what are we going to do with them
so generally there are six
classifications of mammalian cancers and
they're all they're named from the the
cell the type of cell from which they
originate
carcinoma is the name given to
malignancies that start in epithelial
cells
so these carcinomas derive from cells
from the skin from
specific organs you've got basal cells
in the skin the thyroid is epithelium
lungs liver colorectal cancers are all
examples of carcinomas
and most
cancers are
are carcinomas
sarcomas occur in the tissues that are
between the organs so connective tissues
such as muscle tendons and bones are
classified as sarcomas
leukemia and lymphoma are both blood
cancers
leukemia originates in the white blood
cells within the bone marrow
these malignant white blood cells
migrate out of the bone marrow and go
into the bloodstream
they circulate around the body therefore
it's not a solid tumor
it can be detected throughout the whole
body
so lymphoma
also develops from white blood cells
but unlike leukemia
it's a solid tumor it forms within the
lymph nodes within the lymphatic system
so it doesn't circulate around the body
malignant melanoma develops from
specialized skin cells called
melanocytes
now these specialized skin cells produce
melanin pigment
which is a brown insoluble deposit and
it's responsible for the different
shades of skin that we see
we'll discuss malignant melanoma in a
bit more detail in a few slides time
and finally the last one is central
nervous system tumors
so these arise from nerves from the
spinal cord and from the brain
due to medical developments over the
last 200 years
we humans are living much longer
so this increased lifespan combined with
various lifestyle choices that we make
mean we are more susceptible to cancer
so in a very simplified description
cancer is uncontrolled cell growth
when cells grow
what they do is they divide they make a
copy of the dna
for each new cell that produces so one
cell will divide into two
so the first cell
makes a copy of its dna and that copy
will go into cell two the second cell
will make a copy and that will go into
cell 3 a third copy of the dna
this third copy will make a fourth copy
and so on and so on
with the dna being duplicated each time
it's at a risk of damage
every time dna
is
is replicated you run the risk of a
mistake in the sequence
think of it as a very very broad
comparison with photocopying
so when you have your single copy
you have an original document sorry you
make a single copy and it's very clear
it's sharp
it's crisp
now if you take that copy and make
another copy
and keep doing that and making copies of
each copy
by the time you get to the 10th the 20th
the 30th
you can't see the clarity that you had
in the first one
it's not sharp it's not crisp it's not
clean it's blurred
linking it back to the cells
every time your dna is copied
it's getting blurry which would mean
it's a potential mistake in the dna
sequence
so we've got a piece of dna or a mistake
in the dna
which can trigger malignant changes
this
change in the dna sequence can result in
the over expression of protein the under
expression of protein different proteins
which is what we will detect with
antibodies
malignant melanoma is one of the most
prevalent cancers in males and females
it starts when the sun's rays damage the
dna and the melanocytes
and this damage causes the switch that
usually stops the cells from dividing
it turns it off and the cells just keep
dividing and dividing and dividing
so the top image
on the screen
is a typical clinical presentation of
malignant melanoma
the outline of the darkened area it's
irregular the colour's uneven
and they are both very very common
symptoms for a malignant melanoma
but we need to make sure
that the changes are due
to these damaged melanocytes so biopsy
of the lesion will be taken
that biopsy will be processed in a
pathology lab
and from this an h e slide will be
generated and that's what's in the
middle image
h e is hematoxylineasin
so hematoxylin is a dye which stains
cell nuclei blue so you can see the dna
or you can see the
nucleolus where the dna is contained
an eosin is a dye which stains the rest
of the cellular components various
shades of pink
the brown area now this is the melanin
pigment the naturally occurring
insoluble melanin pigment
while the h e is used to visualize the
tissue structure
we need to use immunohistochemistry
and that's what's seen in the lower
image
so this shows the tissue which has been
stained with an antibody that was
generated against a specific protein
called
45
now hmv 45 protein is only expressed by
malignant melanocytes
not normal melanocytes just malignant
melanocytes
so an antibody created against hmb
hmb-45
will then identify lesions which are
malignant melanomas
but the antibodies are microscopic
they're invisible to the naked eye and
even at a very high magnification
you can't see them
so we tag them with specific enzymes
these enzymes horseradish peroxidase
react with another reagent called dab
to produce a rich brown insoluble
precipitate at the location
where the antibody has bound to the
antigen structure in the tissue
so it's a much stronger
richer deeper brown than what you see
with the normal melanin pigment so you
can differentiate between the two
hematoxylin is commonly used as a
counter stain and this allows you to be
able to identify the tissue structure so
you can see
if the layer of skin where the malignant
melanocytes are
you can see if they've moved out of that
layer and into underlying tissues
now
immunohis chemistry
is the the technique that we use
to use the antibodies for
diagnosing
disease and training materials for
immunohistochemistry are also available
on the life science portal of the leica
biosystems website
so we've discussed malignant melanoma
but all through the body
every single cell or nearly every single
cell has the potential to become
malignant
and each
different tumor
that arises from these malignant cells
will have a different protein expression
profile
having said that
some
proteins are expressed by a wide range
of normal and malignant tissues
so it could be that using a single
antibody
is not the most reliable method
it is with hnb 45 but generally with
other
cancers it's not
several different tumor types can
express the same protein
they can lose the same protein
they can express the same modified
protein
so it's common to use a variety of
antibodies during testing
and some of these will you will expect
to be negative and some of these you
would expect to be positive
so negative would be no antibody
staining and positive would be detection
of the antibody
and it's this stealing profile that
gives you an answer
on this slide we have several examples
of abnormalities in epithelial cells and
antibodies that are commonly used to
identify them
image one shows positive staining for
the antibody raised against high
molecular weight cytokeratin
ck ae1 and ae3
the antibody is bound to cells
expressing
these specific cytokeratins
so it's a very close-up image of a
ductal breast cancer
the breast the the ductal cancer cells
are are the ones expressing the cke1 and
e3
image 2 demonstrates bowel carcinoma
and it's displaying positivity for cdx2
protein
the bowel has a mucosal
lining
and the mucosal cells have become
malignant and they've spread through the
underlying tissue
where they shouldn't normally be
using antibodies raised against the cdx2
protein allows a clearer identification
of the malignant cells among the normal
cells
so the brown cells the malignant cells
and
the the bluey cells around it are normal
cells
image three is an example of prostatic
ductal hypoplasia
prostatic ducts express prostatic
specific antigen or psa
using this antibody
allows clear visualization of the
thickening ducts so they shouldn't be
that thick than normal
um
prostate
now hyperplasia is not a true malignancy
but it's still an abnormal change that
arises from a specific epithelial cell
type
the last one image 4 is a normal human
thyroid and it's been stained with
antibodies raised against thyroid
transcription factor 1
which we also call ttf1
so whilst the name in the tissue
suggests ttf1 is used in diagnosing
thyroid tumors it is but it's also used
in identifying lung tumors
so ttf1 protein is commonly expressed in
type 2 pneumocytes in the lung
when the cells undergo malignant changes
they continue to express ttf1 which
allows the identification of lung
adenocarcinoma
so
in this webinar we've looked at the
structure of antibodies
we've learned the nomenclature for each
region how the structure supports the
function
we've looked at the five different
isotypes and the function in the human
body
briefly we've discussed the manufacture
of antibodies and how they're used to
determine different types of cancer
we've touched on why a longer lifespan
means a greater risk of cancer
developing later in life
and it's this increased risk that makes
the production of high quality
antibodies
for use and reproducible
immunohistochemistry techniques
extremely valuable to cancer researchers
around the world
thank you for listening
i hope you enjoyed it and
i'm happy to answer any questions
thank you
thank you denise for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen we'll answer as many of your
questions as we have time for so let's
get started our first question asks
how long does it take to produce a
monoclonal antibody for commercial use
on average
right well
as i mentioned monoclonal antibodies are
far more specific than polyclonal
so
you need to have several different
dilutions
to isolate the individual single clone
now before you even get to that
you've got to make sure that the horse
animal has an immune response to it
because sometimes they don't
now the first time you make an antibody
the very very first time
it has to use an animal
once you've made it and then you've
created this hybrid adenoma
you do no longer you no longer need to
reinfect or to re-inoculate host animals
your hybridoma that you will create from
a single
immortalized b cell clone
this individual cell will then be
cultured it will grow and it will
develop into
you know a
field of cells across the bottom of a of
a cell plate
you can then
isolate some of these cells freeze them
and
use them again in the future as long as
you treat them right you can thaw them
and
re-culture them and keep them growing so
you can have an unlimited supply
of these b cells that are producing your
specific antibody
so whilst it is a long time which is
about
two to three months initially
from isolating the splenic b cells from
the animal
it
for those two to three months you then
have unlimited supply as long as you
treat your harvested cells nicely
they will continue to grow and they will
continue to produce your specific
antibody
so
two to three months
maybe is longer sometimes up to six
months depending on what what the cells
what the proteins are how the cells
adapt it's a biological system so you
can't say for definite it should take
three weeks to the day
bodies and human cells don't work like
that so
so it can take quite a while
i hope that answers the question
great thank you
next question here
you mentioned how monoclonal antibodies
are created is the process different for
polyclonal antibodies
so yes it is
it's shorter which is what makes them
cheaper
and there's less involvement in it
so with the monoclonal you need to keep
doing these individual dilutions
until you get a single cell
in a single plate
with the polyclonal you don't need
that extreme amount of dilutions
you end up with a few clones
which makes it a shorter period of time
so
it can be two
two months
from
the creation of the hybridoma
um
sometimes
you know it takes longer as i've said
before it's a biological system it
doesn't always work as expected
but as with the monoclonal antibodies
you can actually freeze them and restore
them and look after them right and again
have an unlimited supply
of cells that will produce your unique
polyclonal antibody
so it's quicker
but
it still has the same knock-on effect or
or once you've created it it has
the same kind of response as monoclonal
antibody production does
great thank you we've got some great
questions coming in from our audience
here so we'll proceed this next one asks
where do you see the future of ihc with
the onset of more
molecular based testing
right
now i remember years ago when i worked
in the hospital laboratory so my
background is cellular pathology
in um in
in a hospital in the uk
and we were all told about molecular
testing oh it's coming along it's
individual
you know it's allowing us to be
specific to the individual to create
personalized treatment and everything
and we all thought oh that means we're
going to get rid of our
immunohistochemistry machinery
that will never happen
and the reason being ihc is so much
cheaper than molecular testing
so
thinking about it when you when you're a
patient and you present
at
your doctor with a lump
just because it could be
you know just because it's in the throat
doesn't mean it's going to be a throat
cancer
so
you would end up having to have all of
these diagnostic tests
immunohistochemistry is very quick
in comparison to
to um to some tests that can be done
it's
two or three hours and
if you use the right antibodies over a
few slides
you will end up with a very accurate
diagnosis and that sometimes is all you
need
now
as technology is developing and we are
getting into more and more molecular it
will molecular testing will become
quite routine i do believe
but i think it will
be secondary to immunohistochemistry
because immunohistochemistry will narrow
it down to a specific type is it a lung
cancer is it a bowel cancer is it a
breast cancer
and then from there you will know which
molecular tests to do
to get this personalized treatment
response
from your clinician
so
i don't ever see ihc
being replaced by molecular i see them
working alongside each other but that is
my opinion
i might be wrong i don't know
that's very interesting thank you denise
next question here
you taught us that antibodies are
y-shaped why is that important to
antibody functioning
so your antibodies the important thing
that they do is they label something
that's not you that's foreign
they tag it
but
your own individual cells need to be
able to recognize
that this antibody has tagged something
nasty
that your immune cells have to create a
reaction
to this tagged pathogen
with this y structure you've got the two
arms
they tag they attached to the epitopes
on the antigen
but the the long the one leg or the
the one part of the structure that is
the constant domain um and the fc region
that
is easily recognizable
by your immune cells
which means it can the antibodies can go
and detect any pathogen that it's raised
against but the immune cells
which are going to do the destruction
of the the pathogen will recognize it
and will bind to it
and with igm and
igg
it will trigger phagocytosis or with iga
it'll start it'll bind it and prevent it
from invading the body
and
it'll push it the
lungs will cough it up other bowels will
push it out so the shape is very
important
to its uh to its function
great thank you
it looks like we have time for one more
question here so we'll go ahead and wrap
up after this one
does the two-part structure of an
antibody have separate functions
well yeah that's kind of
what i've just just mentioned really so
you've got your two y arms and at the
end of these y arms
is the antigen binding site
if you don't
have
an antigen binding site then this
pathogen is not going to be detected so
the individual amino acids at the end of
the arms will have a specific sequence
that will
detect
this epitope on the pathogen and the the
leg the
the longer part of the y structure
that function is totally to be
recognized and to trigger your immune
reaction
so your your upper part is to do the
detection of
the pathogens and the lower part
is to
say to your immune system hey come on
we've got to attack this can you can you
do your phagocytosis on this bit now
thank you very much so two separate
functions
but work so well together and protect
our bodies
great
well thank you again denise for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor leica biosystems for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
laborats will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone goodbye
thank you bye
you